but basically he testified in front of
congress and here's some of the
highlights of that and i want to get
your opinions on the other side of this
so he basically said right now the
number one goal is to combat inflation
right so quote unquote
jerome powell says the fed has the tools
and the resolve to restore price
stability in america
right we understand the hardships high
inflation is causing among american
citizens we are strongly committed to
bringing back down inflation he added
that gdp is picking back up consumption
is strong
but
but the housing market is softening due
to a spike in mortgage rates plus future
rates hikes are coming i think they
announced it a couple more hikes
throughout the rest of this year they
just raised it uh
50 basis points i want to say 75 basis
points uh a week ago i want to say um
and then lastly he says but overall the
american economy is strong and well
positioned to fight inflation so george
as a financial expert would you please
uh help us make sense of what's going on
here in america first of all i don't
know how the economy can be strong when
in q1 it contracted by 1.5 percent
so think about that
we have negative gdp growth right now
when you adjust for inflation so he's
saying literally the economy is
contracting but it's really really
strong
so i always call it a recessionary boom
right that's probably how the media and
the administration is going to spin it
but another thing that he said in there
a couple of the you know the politicians
asked him about the probability of a
recession he says well you never really
know he said no one can really predict a
recession and uh you know we've never
been able to do it in the past so no one
can do it now and that's just utter
nonsense because we have something
called a yield curve right and it's when
you look at the treasury curve
especially the twos and the tens so it's
the two-year treasury and the 10-year
treasury going back to 1950 or so when
that thing inverts you've got almost a
100 probability that you get a recession
within 18 to 24 months and so we've had
that curve actually invert twice in the
last maybe three or four months
so
that that is just
patently false when he says that no one
can predict a recession maybe the fed
can't predict a recession uh but that
yield curve sure can and so now does
that mean that there's a 100 probability
that we get a recession no but it's just
something that's had a very high
predictive ability in the past so it's
something we should really pay attention
to
another thing is i don't get too far in
the weeds but something called the euro
dollar future curve uh inverted to
december of 22. so what that's saying
is the really smart money is betting
that the fed will actually start
lowering rates in 2022
not not raising them but actually
lowering rates and the only reason they
would do that is because the stock
market crashes like we saw
in
in march of 2020 or we get a recession
potentially depression we get two or
three quarters of negative real gdp
growth and that's why they'd start
dropping rates now what's interesting is
how do they do that if the negative gdp
growth is a result of an inflationary
recession right so if you've got so if
nominal gdp is going up by let's say
five percent
but inflation is running at six percent
that's negative one percent when you
adjust for that rate of inflation we
call it real
gdp real gdp
so if real gdp is negative but yet it's
still highly inflationary you know can
they drop rates down to zero again can
they do more quantitative easing this
has been their game plan for the last
two or three decades but they've always
executed that plan with a backdrop of
disinflation where inflation was
actually going lower so they're kind of
they've painted themselves into a corner
where if we get a recession that's
inflationary that the tools in their
tool kit will only make things worse
right so it's like you've got to choose
do you want to prop up the economy or
do you want to
fight inflation because you can't have
both right and so i think it becomes a
political question where the politicians
say okay we've got to choose between the
stock market and inflation and so
what are we going to choose based on the
highest probability of getting reelected
and i think it it's kind of on a
month-by-month basis i don't know if i
could project out to determine you know
i think it's going to be really
narrative based so if i'm the
administration and let's say uh
inflation
uh
goes down it's at 8.6 right now headline
cpi so let's say it goes down to seven
percent
i think they want to bring it down their
goals to five percent by the end of the
year i mean yeah yeah so it it well if
it's trending down they can say well
look what we've done to
combat uh putin's price hikes you know
they always blame it on putin or
something uh it has nothing to do with
the fact that our money supply increased
by 25 in 2020 but they'll say that at
least it's going in the right direction
we're doing things you know vote for me
because we've really got a handle on
inflation and we're sticking it to those
greedy capitalists that are just raising
prices for no reason other than just a
screw the poor and middle class that's
kind of going to be the narrative so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
[Music]